anita you are gonna love it here
it's about time we got a real vacation
it's not a vacation no good can come
from this place it's got time
see even tabio gets it he doesn't get
anything
oh come on look at this place pristine
beaches exotic wildlife all the good
vibes you could ever watch i mean this
water is so ripple oh oh
right okay that's wow can someone get
walter a towel please
we're too exposed out here we should get
to high ground
you just need to learn how to relax
so can you get my back
i'm never leaving this place
[Music]
[Music]
oh brother
[Applause]
hey
are you relaxed now
guys
you're ruining beach day
i thought you at least should be a
challenge
this way
okay yeah nice to meet you too i guess
[Music]
wow what kind of captain crashes his own
ship
what
you not believe the deductible on these
things by the way
[Music]
hmm humans
so fragile
[Music]
well that's terrifying
[Music]
okay none of this was in the brochure
reed
dr summers
you should have stayed where i left you
how disappointing no no that's it i'm
done i'm going back to the boat
you're alive
let's go
you